a few of you have been asking which
phones are going to fit inside the
real-life Pip Boy which is shipping with
the pip-boy edition of fallout 4 well
today we can tell you not to I can tick
ones tablet owners be where your
sizeable iPhone 6 pluses and the like
will not be able to shimmy their way
into the replica pip-boy to run the
fallout 4 companion app as you play
opposed to the bethesda blog may have -
the role-playing dreams of giant phone
owners but the death had confirmed that
the device will feature foam inserts for
iPhone 6 iPhone 5 and 5s iPhone 4 and 4s
Samsung Galaxy 5 samsung galaxy 4 and a
number of smartphones similar to those
sizes if you do have a big phone you can
still run the companion app but you
won't be able to visit inside the
pip-boy so if you have your heart set on
strapping a cumbersome piece of plastic
to your arm while you play a video game
you may want to think twice before you
drop a hundred and twenty bucks on this
special edition let me know down in the
comments if your phone is going to fit
into the real-life Pip Boy and we'll
keep you updated on everything fallout 4
on GameSpot